Musik Meine Damen und Herren, hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Ufo Podcast P, O, das dauert viel zu lange. Ich sage Podcast, du sagst Ufo, Podcast, Lobo, Podo, wir sind es wieder in einem Raum. Nimmst du schon auf? Kann ich eine mega Anekdote erzählen? Du ist Hauchhaus, Mensch, ey, was soll der Geiz? Wir sind immer wieder heute in einem Raum zusammen. Die beste Anekdote am Anfang heute, einfach mal haushauen. Nein, überhaupt gar nicht. Ich habe keine Anekdote zu erzählen. Es ist nur so, dass wir quasi heute wieder unverfälscht gegenüber sitzen. Also Skype kann nichts kaputt machen, wir sitzen genau gegenüber. Wir können uns berühren, warte. Wir berühren uns kurz. Das waren unsere Penisse. Penis direkt zu Anfang. Sehr gut, gleich oben. So ein bisschen klar zu machen, wo heute hinwollen. Und es ist doch so, kennst du dieses Video von den Star Trek-Leuten, wo das Wackeln des Raumschiffes rausgemacht wurde und man nur die Leute sieht, wie sie krampig versuchen, irgendwie ihre Show durchzubringen? Genauso ist es bei uns heute irgendwie. Die technischen Fähigkeiten sind da und man sieht, unsere Fähigkeiten liegen heute ein bisschen brach. Das heißt, wir wackeln gerade irgendwie auch so rum. Ich glaube, wenn man bei uns auch alle technischen Massnahmen rausnehmen würde, also der Equalizer, der Regulator, der Terminator, der Devastator, der Anheilator, wenn man alles rauskürzen würde, würde relativ wenig bei uns übrig bleiben tatsächlich. Und das wird heute mal eine nackte Folge. Heute sind wir nackt, wir zielen uns aus emotional bis auf den letzten Rest, auf die Essenz, bis auf das Donutloch haben wir uns heute reduziert, um euch heute mal endlich wieder eine gute Folge zu präsentieren, denn man muss ja sagen, die letzte Folge war nicht ganz so hundertprozentig gut, wir waren nicht da, wir haben auch eine harsche Kritik bekommen, von, wie ist der, wollte ich nur kurz noch eingehen. Also mittlerweile von konstruktiver Kritik gehen wir schon einen Schritt weiter in Richtung, wir therapieren die Moderatoren in der Hoffnung, dass wir sie irgendwann irgendwann so bekommen, dass sie komplett ausgeglichen da stehen.
Klar, du, Podcast-Ufo ist auch primär ein Therapieprojekt für mich. Also wir therapieren Zuhörer und Zuhörer therapieren uns. So habe ich mir das eigentlich von Anfang an vorgestellt.
Nur wir therapieren Zuhörer schlecht und sie therapieren uns gut.
Sehr schlecht, ja, aber dafür nehmen wir sehr, sehr viel Geld. Und zwar haben wir einen Kommentar bekommen von Stefan Schwier, vielen Dank dafür, auf unserer Webseite. Und zwar hat er geschrieben bezüglich auf die letzte Folge, die Folge war ein wenig melancholisch, aber nicht schlecht. Also erstmal vielen Dank dafür. Wollen wir erstmal vorlesen und Satz für Satz direkt durchgehen. Ja, okay. Ich würde erstmal kurz drüber fliegen, einfach mal einen kurzen Eindruck geben und dann können wir nochmal alles direkt. Stefan hat ein bisschen durchblicken lassen, weshalb, nämlich die Angst, seine Zeit zu verschwenden und damit die Chance, auf eine gute Zukunft zu verbauen. Ein Gefühl, was jeder kennt, die häufig auftauchen, in Lebensphasen oder Situationen, wenn man mehr auf andere achtet als auf sich selbst. Fader Beigeschmack von Selbstmitleid, was aber vollkommen normal ist. Was ich lustig finde, ist, dass ich ihn so beneide um seine Karriere, er aber trotzdem glaubt, es nicht zu schaffen. Ja, sprich ruhigführungszeichen, wo keine Sinn. Doch, genau das ist genau der erste Punkt. Ich finde es einfach so ein geiler Satz, so Widerspruch in einem Satz, ich beneide ihn um seine und dann in Anführungszeichen Karriere. Oder was auch immer das gerade ist, was er anbietet. Das ist so nett, das genau so sagt, Oh, ich bin so neidisch auf deine Freundin. So, what? Ja, danke, aber ja, also finde ich herrlich. Karriere auch einfach mal falsch geschrieben. Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Gag sein soll, dass er das Wort Karriere bei dir falsch schreibt. Vor allem da ist dieser eine Satz, der anfängt mit einem, er hat durchblicken lassen, weshalb, wo ich auch nicht ganz verstehe, was dieser Halbsatz in diesem Satz soll, oder ob der noch irgendwo hinführt. Will der vollendet? Nee, oder? Nein. Nein, der wird nicht vollendet, der Satz. So, Florent hat sich die erste Dose Booster aufgemacht. Ab jetzt geht es stimmungsmäßig back. Nee, aber finde ich ganz interessant, tatsächlich, weil er analysiert, dass die Folge melancholisch ist, weil es dir schlecht geht. Was nicht stimmte, weil es eigentlich mir letzte Woche schlecht ging und ich meine emotionalen Probleme durchzuarbeiten hatte. Nee, das habe ich auch gemerkt. Deine Emotionalen Probleme hast du irgendwie auf meiner Befindlichkeitslage irgendwie abgestapelt. Ja, aber ich verstehe gar nicht, wie das sein kann, dass wenn es mir schlecht geht, du schlechter Performer bist. Bist du so ein empathischer Mensch? Nein, ich bin ein Reaktionstyp. Und wenn ich merke, dass Gags nicht ankommen, werde ich unfassbar schnell, falle ich in ein sehr tiefes Loch und da weiß ich ja nicht, wie ich da rauskomme, weil ich dann immer denke, boah, halt einfach die Fresse. Ja, ich gebe dir auch immer Thumbs up hier. Ich kann mir selber nicht zuhören. Wenn wir in einem Raum sitzen, gebe ich dir immer direkt Thumbs up, wenn der Gag gut war, einfach um direkt positives Feedback zu. Man kann mich extrem gut machen, indem man sehr oft lacht und sehr extrovertiert über meine Witze lacht. Jetzt bin ich top drauf für diese Folge. Ja, absolut, klar, natürlich. Aber das ist ja auch normal. Also man ist ja auch immer so eine Symbiose zwischen Zuhörer und Ablieferer. Man kann nur abliefern, wenn man halt auch dementsprechend die Reaktion bekommt. Und ich glaube auch, dass wir zu dem Schlag Menschen gehören, also einfach natürlicherweise, dass wir auch Bestätigung brauchen einfach. Und von Bestätigung leben. Alle die Leute, die irgendwie vom Mikro, vor der Kamera was machen wollen. Ja klar, natürlich, weil wir glaube ich funktionieren nur mit objektiver Rückmeldung, dass wir sagen, okay, die Person lacht, die Person hat mir einen Daumen hochgegeben, das ist objektive Rückmeldungung im Gegensatz zu anderen Menschen, die dann so Sachen wie Zuneigung und Mitgefühl und Liebe und so ein Kram haben. Boring, gay, was man vielleicht nicht ganz so gut abmessen kann, deswegen, also wenn ihr uns gut findet, bitte sagt uns regelmäßig, dass wir gut sind, weil sonst werden wir melancholisch. Da gibt es diesen Gag, wenn ihr uns nicht gut findet, dann sagt euren Feinden, wie ihr uns findet. Aber ich auch nicht ganz so, dass Strassenkünstler und schlechte Comedians sagen das immer. Empfehlt mich weiter, wenn du mich gut fandest, wenn du mich nicht gut fandest, dann macht es trotzdem. Das ist immer dieser Rausgeher-Satz, wo er immer herzliches Gelächter erntet, wo ich mir auch frage, warum. Wo ich dann auch als jemand, der sich mit Comedy beschäftigt, am Rand stehe und einfach nur mit dem Kopf schüttelt und ein bisschen böse in die Runde gucke,
ist das euer Ernst?
Wo ich mir dann auch plötzlich in den Kreis stelle, der sich da gebildet hat.
Was soll das? Ganz kurz, kommt ihr mal ganz kurz rüber?
Was war das? Warum habt ihr da gelacht?
Genau, analysieren, da muss man nachfragen, warum.
Das ist auch eine Ausdruck an euch, wenn ihr lacht oder Leute lachen
und ihr habt nachher gedacht, warum haben wir da eigentlich gelacht, sprecht das mal an.
Macht euch das mal bewusst, warum ihr da gerade lacht. In 90 Prozent der Fälle aus Quatsch oder aus Dazugierigkeitsgefühlen oder warum.
Ich habe dir in der Woche den Link geschickt zu diesem Britain's Got Talent.
Ja, die habe ich direkt weggetrückt.
Ach nee, das habe ich gesehen.
Aber den fand ich so lustig, weil man fragt sich ja oft, wenn man so Gags hört, so was ist der schlechteste Gag der Welt? Und in welcher Situation wird der präsentiert und wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Es gab eine Szene bei Britain's Got Talent, so einer klassischen Talent-Show, wo man eben, wo Personen auf die Bühne gehen müssen. Ja, der Super-Talent auf den Jury. Ja, ja. Ich weiss doch nicht, ich kenne mich da nicht aus. Auf jeden Fall war dann eine Frau, die meinte, sie war auf einer Comedy-School, hat einen Comedy-Kurs gemacht für 200 Dollar. Was, mal ohne Scheiß, mal kurz da schon Stopp. Es ist der uncoolste Einstieg in ein Comedy-Programm. Ja, ich bin die so und so Elisabeth Dreischoff und ich kann, ich mache jetzt Comedy und weil ich war auf einer Comedy-Schule. Ja, aber dann würde die so anfangen, failen. Ich glaube, von Simon Cowell heißt der Typ, die perfekte Antwort, wie viel hast du dafür gezahlt, was wirklich scharf ist, weil das ist genau richtig und dann so 200 Dollar und er halt, okay, good luck, jetzt kommt der 200 Dollar Gag. Arme verschränkt, zurückgelehnt, okay, good luck, come on, do it. Jetzt kommt der 200 Dollar Gag und vor allem, ich finde es auch so lustig, weil das ist natürlich auch wieder ein Bilderbuchbeispiel für das Publikum schwingt in der Meinung, Stimmungsschwankung. Also das heißt, sie kommt dann auf die Bühne und sagt, okay, jetzt kommt mein Witz. Are you alright? Und alle, yeah, also wahnsinnig unverdient, wahnsinnig gelauert, denkst du, okay, geil, Comedian, ideal. Ja genau, aber ist es nämlich auch so, dass man, wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt ein Stand-up hört, dass man bei einem Publikum sitzt, lacht und wirklich zu Hause vom Rechner vielleicht gar nicht lachen würde? Kann gut sein, ne? Kann das sein? Ja, wahrscheinlich schon. Sagt man noch zu Hause vom Rechner oder ist das auch schon so ein Ding? Also ich schon, ich lache schon ab und zu. Du sagst vom Rechner, sagst du auch? Ich sag LOL dann laut halt. Okay. LOL und schreib das dann auf dem Zettel. Aber auch vom Rechner. Vor deinem Rechner. Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum du das jetzt so betonst, aber tatsächlich. Mir ist es lustig, dass ich das gesagt habe. Der Rechner? Ja, dass ich plötzlich anfange, wie ein 50-Jähriger zu sprechen. Echt? Ich dachte, Rechner wäre so LAN-Party-Sprech. Nein. Nee? Die sagen Desktop-PC. Nee, die sagen schon Rechner. Oder das ist äquivalent zu dem englischen Machine. Oder Funbox. Meine Funbox. Oder haben die vielleicht auch Namen für ihre... Das ist eine Einbahnstraße. Auf nach dem Haus. Zurück zu dem Auftritt von dieser Frau, die gesagt hat, Are you all right? Yay! No, you are all, all left. Und dann einfach komplett Stille. Nee, er war Stille, dann gab es diese geilen Umschnitte auf Leute, die sich fragend angeguckt haben. Im Publikum so... Schnitt auf Publikum, alle katastrophal. Eine Freundin war irgendwie dabei. Genau, die Freundin ist ja das allerbeste, die Begleitung im Publikum, dann einfach so die Hände vor den Mund so. What the, was so? Was zur Hölle? Dann Schnitt auf hinter die Bühne, alle auch Kabelhilfen und so, alle völlig verwirrt. Und dann plötzlich hört man ja bei, was natürlich ganz lustig ist, bei Supertalent, hat man immer diese Buzzer, wenn Leuten das gar nicht gefällt, wo man sofort raus ist und plötzlich wird diese awkward Stille nur durchbrochen von diesem Buzzers hauen, dieses Däh, Däh, Däh, Däh, Däh, einfach gnadenlos weggebuzzert. Weil es die beste Reaktion auf einen schlechten Gag ist, das ist wirklich die beste Reaktion, Stille und dann Däh, Däh. Was schon einfach mal geil ist, dass man auch direkt nach dem ersten Gag schon jemanden rausbasert und dann einfach die, also eine grossartige Szene.
Und das ist natürlich so ein Punkt, wo man, wo ich auch dankbar bin, weil man sagt, okay, der schlechteste Gag der Welt. Und da kann man analysieren, warum hat der Gag nicht funktioniert, warum hat, warum war der nicht lustig, weil die Stimmung war gut, 200 Euro, 200 Dollar wurden ausgegeben für diesen Gag. Im Grunde eigentlich alles in Richtung, die Erwartungshaltung war sehr hoch, aber gut. Aber auch dankbar. Also man hätte auch nicht gewünscht, dass es einen guten Gag für 200 Dollar zu bekommen.
Weil 200 Dollar ist auch nicht so viel.
Nee, und die war schwarz, kann man auch mal sagen.
Ob man das sagen muss, weiss ich nicht.
Doch, und da hat man gesagt, also da war man auch nö.
Das Publikum war überwiegend weiss.
Du meinst, für sie ist das viel Geld, oder was? Worauf willst du hinaus?
Für ihren Stamm wäre das viel Geld.
Dafür hat sie drei ihrer Kinder verkauft.
Und ihren Mann, ein Pferd.
Was?
Du musst lachen, ich falle mir in so ein Loch, jetzt ist es wieder vorbei.
Ja, okay, mein Gott.
Ja, und das ist wirklich, es war auch vor allem, hat es wenig Sinn ergeben.
Das ist, glaube ich, das Hauptproblem dieses Gags, dass der Sinn einfach gen Null strebte, weil you're all left, all all left. Ja, ergebt keinen Sinn, wenn das gesamte Publikum auf der linken Saalseite gesessen hätte, dann hätte es Sinn ergeben, aber es war einfach so losgelöst, es hatte einfach keinen Kontext. Gags brauchen immer Kontext, kann man daraus ziehen. Man kann aus jedem gefailten Gag auch eigentlich daraus ziehen, dass eine Lehre ziehen. Wie aus einer Fabel. Und da wäre jetzt halt die Lehre, dass man Gags immer in einem Kontext tun sollte und es immer auch irgendwie Sinn ergeben sollte. Kann man wirklich aus jeder Fabel eine Lehre ziehen? Ja, klar. Gebt ein Beispiel. Die Fabel mit dem Bären und dem Skorpion. Da kann man daraus ziehen, dass man Bären und Skorpione nicht in einem Gehege halten sollte. Das war letztes Wochen im Zoo, ich meine die Fabel jetzt. Ah, okay. Die Fabel, daraus kann man ziehen, dass Bären Skorpione zum Fressen gern haben. Das war ein Frosch, glaube ich. Und ich glaube, die Fabel geht so, dass der Skorpion will über den Fluss und der Frosch kann nicht und der Frosch sagt, jo, Alter, was geht, ich gehe jetzt mit dem Fluss hier rüber, du kannst nicht und dann sagt der Skorpion, nee, du kannst mir ja helfen und dann sagt der Frosch, ja, aber... Aber der Frosch darf nicht mit dem Skorpion gleichzeitig an der anderen Seite sein und der Bär darf nicht mit dem... Der hat einen Fuchs auf der anderen Seite, warten noch, es gibt nur ein Schiff. Und genau, man macht dieses Rätsel noch besser, indem es statt einem Boot einfach ein Skorpion ist, einfach der dann random sticht. Zufallsfaktor noch mit drin. Oder eine Schildkröte, die das Boot ist, auf dem Wasser. Ja, das stimmt. Und dann hat der, dann sagt der Skorpion, dann sagt der Frosch, ja, aber du stichst mich ja. Und dann sagt der Skorpion, nee, hundertprozentig, warum soll ich den stechen, dann würden wir ja beide untergehen. Und dann sagt der Frosch, ja, aber du stichst mich ja, und dann sagt der Skorpion,
nee, hundertprozentig, warum soll ich den stechen, dann würden wir ja beide untergehen,
und dann sagt der Frosch, ja, okay, es ergibt Sinn, und nimmt den Skorpion auf seinen Rücken,
schwimmt durch einen halben Fluss, und auf der Hälfte des Fluss sticht der Skorpion den Frosch,
beide sterben, und im Sterben fragt der Frosch noch so, ja, Alter, was, warum, was war das
jetzt für eine Aktion, warum hast du mich gestochen, und dann sagt der Skorpion, weil ich ein Skorpion bin. Und die Moral soll so ein bisschen sein, dass Rassismus im Endeffekt ist es eigentlich, dass Vorurteile tatsächlich wahr sind. und dass der Frosch wirklich verdammt gut daran getan hätte, wenn er den Skorpion einfach auf der anderen Flussseite zurückgelassen hätte.
Im Grunde ist das die Botschaft.
Es ist immer so einfach, ist ein bisschen Ockhams Rasiermesser, weil ich schmeiße heute mit solchen Sachen um mich. Uiuiuiui. Die Einfachstecklerin ist immer die richtige, genau wie bei diesen Lehren vom Struwelpeter, dieses im Internet auch sehr gefeierte deutsche Phänomen von Lehren. Also es ist sehr einfach, der Suppenkasper, der seine Suppe nicht aufisst, immer dünner wird und im Endeffekt so dünn ist, dass er stirbt. Dann der Daumenlutscher, dem dann der Daumen abgeschnitten wird, weil der böse Mann mit der Schere kommt, der nichts besseres zu tun hat als Daumenlutschern die Daumen. Was auch eine fragwürdige Moral ist, weil es ja eigentlich keine Moral ist.
Moral wäre ja, es gibt gewisse Gründe, warum du das nicht tun sollst.
Zähne werden schief. Aber der Scherenmann ist ja genau die falsche Richtung, weil es ist ja sozusagen, es ist ja so wie eine Gott, dadurch hast du ja gerade keine Moral, weil du so eine Art Gottfigur hast, die dann interveniert und sagt, ich schneide dir den Daumen ab. Das heißt eigentlich genau das Gegenteil von der Moral. Es heisst ja auch eigentlich, dass du entweder, du kannst zwei Sachen in deinem Leben machen, du solltest dich an zwei Dinge halten.
Suppe essen? Das heisst eigentlich genau das Gegenteil von der Moral. Vor allem, es heisst ja auch eigentlich, dass du entweder, du kannst zwei Sachen in deinem Leben machen,
du solltest dich an zwei Dinge halten.
Suppe essen.
Suppe essen, okay, Suppe essen, niemals Daumen lutschen und ein normales Leben führen,
oder so ein cooler Scherenmann werden, der Leuten die Daumen abschneidet. Ja, genau. Das ist immer schwer, wenn man in der Story den Protagonisten nicht ganz klar macht.
Dann sagt er so, ja geil, ein cooler Scherenmann. Ich will Berufswunsch-Scherenmann. Ich bin ein cooler Scherenmann. Und ich will auch der Typ sein, Jeff, was machst du, da kannst dein Bruder nicht den Daumen abschneiden. Doch, ich bin der Typ. Aber er hat einen Daumen gelutscht. Schwierig. Ich habe die Geschichte sehr wörtlich genommen. Also, lass uns mal ein bisschen über Hörer reden. Ich finde, Hörer sind eine ganz fantastische Gattung. Hört mal kurz weg. Also vor allem, wir haben genau die Zielgruppe, einfach so, wir reden gerade genau mit den richtigen Leuten über das Thema Hörer. Ich liebe ja Hörer, es gibt ja verschiedene Arten von Hörern, es gibt die, die man ganz gerne mag, es gibt die, die man nicht so gerne mag, und es ist einfach ein bunt gemischter Haufen und man findet wieder neue Dinge. Es ist wie so eine Pralinen-Schachtel irgendwie, wenn man sie zu lange auf der Heizung stehen lässt, dann ist es eine grosse ungenießbare Masse. Es ist irgendwie wie so eine Celebrations-Backung und wir haben halt nur die Bountys als Hörer, aber das ist ganz okay. Es ist eine sehr langweilige Bounty-Backung. Aber es ist immer toll, weil man trifft viele interessante Leute, man kommt aber auch an Leute, wo man sagt so, hm, interessant. Und ich habe zum Beispiel... Aber auch an Leute, wo man sagt, geh weg. Ja, und ich habe zum Beispiel einen Tweet rausgehauen über Hexenverbrennung im Mittelalter und dann hat jemand drunter geschrieben als Antwort. Weil es aber auch ganz kurz ein Thema ist, dass sie sich auch sehr bewegt.
Also die Hexenverbrennung hat dir persönlich auch zu schaffen gemacht, oder? Aber warum hast du, man denkt sich auch immer, ich lese da immer vor und denke mir, warum hat er das jetzt wieder gemacht? Und denkt man immer, was ist gerade dein Bezug zu Hexenverbrennung? Na, ich habe tatsächlich irgendeine Sendung gesehen, in der Hexen vorkamen, also in der so eine mittelalterliche Welt porträtiert wurde, wo alles auf die Hexen geschoben wurde, was passiert. Und ich fand es einfach so eine tolle Weltsicht, dass man tatsächlich so magische Wesen in der Welt hat, die tatsächlich auch einen Einfluss haben. Die tatsächlich schuld sind an allem, Juden zum Beispiel. Tatsächlich ein Problem sind, ja, und wo man sagt so, ey, diese Scheisshexen, wo einfach die Welt so einfach ist, dass man sagen kann, die Hexen sind für alles verantwortlich und die haben halt wirklich so magische Zauberkräfte, die halt dann irgendwie alles beeinflussen. Gibt es das heute auch? Ja, aber heute kann man natürlich sagen, die Schwarzen sind scheiße oder die Flüchtlinge sind scheiße, aber es hat nicht so diesen Bösewicht-Charakter so. Gab's da auch damals dann so Twitter-Profile, irgendwie mit Hexen welcome und so? Ja, oder Five Things Witches Don't Say oder irgendwie sowas, ja. Ja, gab's da auch so Randgruppen, die dann sagen, also ich nimm gern ein paar Hexen auf und dieses Hexenheim da hinten, das werde ich nicht anzünden.
Ich weiß nicht, gibt es da irgendwie, es macht voll Sinn, diese Metapher geht voll auf. Ich glaube schon, da konnte man sich da auch irgendwelche Filter über seinen, ja gut, jetzt müsste man irgendeine lustige mittelalterliche Form von Facebook einfallen, über den Pranger. Markt, Markt, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall habe ich einen Tweet über Hexenverbrennung rausgehauen und Hexenverb Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall, habe ich einen Tweet über Hexenverbrennungen rausgehauen und Hexenverbrennungen im Mittelalter und da hat jemand drunter geschrieben, im Mittelalter gab es keine Hexenverbrennungen, das war eine Erfindung der revolutionären und fortschrittlichen Renaissance, also so ganz schnippisch, sarkastisch. Also es war sarkastisch und besserwisserisch, es war maximal unangenehm und maximal ... Die tolle Renaissance, nee, das war die tolle Renaissance, und man denkt so, an wen appellierst du hier gerade? Du bashst hier gerade die Renaissance, wem gegenüber, welchem Publikum gegenüber, bei wem denkst du, kommt das an, wer sagt, ja stimmt, diese scheiss Renaissance, also das ist so ein gutes Feindbild, die Renaissance, das ist so, das interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Das andere Großartige, was ich bei dir gelesen habe, ist ja, dass du einen Gag gemacht hast, der ein bisschen spitz war. Das war derselbe. Das war genau derselbe. Zum Thema Hexenverbrennung, ja. Und jemand geschrieben hat, wenn sich das jemand gegen einen anderen gerichtet hätte, dann wäre das ein ganz schön gemeiner... Wäre ja ganz schön geschmacklos gewesen. Wäre das ein ganz schön geschmackloser Gag Was auch supergut ist, weil es halt so Next Level Moralkeule ist. Wenn du was anderes getwittert hättest, wäre es geschmacklos gewesen. What? Wenn du etwas gegen Juden getwittert hättest, wäre es so ein Antisemit. Also das ist grossartig. Ich rege mich nicht darüber auf, was du gemacht hast, sondern was du hättest machen können. Dieses präventive Aufregen. Also unglaublich. Ja, dass wir wir dieses schon eingeatmet haben voller Wut, dieses aufgebläht haben und dann nicht wissen, wohin mit der Wut, wenn man sich nicht verlesen hat oder so. Ja, und vor allem, ich stelle mir den Typen vor, dass er sich wirklich ärgert, dass ich nicht über eine andere Randgruppe getwittert habe, sondern über Hexen so von wegen, ah, ich kann mich jetzt nicht aufregen so. Ach Mensch, wie schön es gewesen wäre, wenn du was... Aber ich habe jetzt einen zweiten Account. Ich habe jetzt mir bei Twitter einen zweiten Account gemacht. Ja. Und da weisst du, da kenne ich mich... Ist es diese Frau, mit der du dich immer triffst, oder was? Da kenne ich, nee, ist ein anderes Zweitprofil. Aber das ist dieses ganz Spannende bei Twitter, dass man einfach sehr schnell sehr wütend werden kann, gerade auch bei Replayern. Und ich möchte das nicht mit meinem Namen, ich möchte einfach nicht mit meinem Namen Hass streuen. Da bin ich eigen. Trotzdem möchte ich aber Hass sähen. Und dafür habe ich mir jetzt ein Zeitprofil gemacht. Ich konnte einfach nicht mehr an mir halten. Du hast auch ein Zeitprofil bestimmt. Ich habe zwei, dritt und viert Profile. Und ich habe ausgefunden, sehr viele Menschen haben das, um andere zu beleidigen einfach. Der Kern ist ja, dass man andere Leute beleidigen will und das nicht mit seinem eigenen Namen können. Das ist diese Internet-Anonymität, die nicht gut ist, aber einem wahnsinnig... Ein riesiges Problem ist.
Es ist ein wahnsinniges Ventil einfach für einen.
Es hilft einem, so ein bisschen loszulassen.
Oh Danny Boy, Danny Boy, Danny Boy, I get knocked down, but I get knocked down, immer wieder wieder wieder und I get knocked down. Willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, zur neuen Folge Das Podcast UFO!
Natürlich heute wieder mit Stefan Titzel! und Titzel und Florentin! Wwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww Kommen wir ein bisschen runter. Hey Stefan, wie geht's dir alles klar? Warte mal, ich bin mal ganz klar. Mir geht's sehr gut. Wir sind nämlich heute mal wieder... Wir machen das nicht komplett nochmal. Wir machen das nicht komplett nochmal. Doch, natürlich machen wir das nochmal. Nein, natürlich nicht. Klar, hey, jo, was geht? Geil, cooler Handshake. Wir haben echt einen guten Handshake eigentlich. Wir sind auch schon so Leute, wo man sagt, okay, die begrüssen sich auf so eine ganz coole Art, die sind cool, der eine von denen trägt ein Comedy-T-Shirt, der eine ist eine zu grosse Nase, ist vielleicht ein lustiger Typ. Glaubst du, wir sind schon so cool, dass es peinlich für andere ist? Ich glaube, Leute, die sich mit uns aufhalten, wo man denkt, okay, die gehören zusammen, und wir uns dann aber so comedy-mäßig absondern, weil wir diesen Drang haben abzuliefern, dann kommt es komisch rüber, für die Leute, die mit uns unterwegs sind. Aber sind wir wie so ein Pärchen, das sich schon so innig irgendwie kennt und so viele Insider hat, dass es für andere peinlich ist? Nein, nein, wir wollen uns beide für uns profilieren, wir wollen uns beide jeweils für uns profilieren. Aber auch vor dem anderen. Vor dem anderen, was dazu führt, dass wir manchmal Hilfe suchen zum Eingucken, manchmal aber auch so ein bisschen süffisant herabblicken auf den anderen, wenn man gerade einen guten Gag gemacht hat. Ja. Was bei Maxi Stettbauer gar nicht gut ankam. Also sozusagen, wir sind sozusagen für den anderen jeweils eine lebende Leiter. Wir klettern aneinander hoch, ne? Aber da der andere auch immer wieder hochklettert, kommt man selber hoch. Wir sind wie ein Parasit. Wir brauchen den anderen, um zu leben, aber wir bringen den anderen auch um. Wir ernähren uns primär von uns selbst. Wir bringen den anderen auch um. Ja. Irgendwann mal. Absolut. Und wir übertragen sehr schlimme Geschlechtskrankheiten. Apropos Geschlechtskrankheiten, Stefan, ich habe die letzte Woche tatsächlich ohne Gürtel verbracht. Ich sehe das. Und das war gar nicht weiss. Ich sehe das gerade, weil deine Hose, die auch in den Kniekehlen hängt, ich weiß nicht. Aber ich habe wirklich komplett aufgegeben, weil ein Leben ohne Gürtel ist nicht lebenswert. Es ist wirklich schlimm, weil ich komme nämlich, ich bin gerade in Köln, ich komme direkt aus München. Man muss immer sagen, du kommst immer aus Berlin oder München oder weiß ich nicht, woher du gerade kommst, Timbuktu hierher und hast immer nur, was ich nicht verstehe, du hast eine Nutebeutel mit an Sachen ungefähr. Also die habe ich jetzt dabei. Du hast wahnsinnig wenige Sachen immer mit. Ich brauche für eine Woche Köln einen Koffer. Allein weil ich sehr viele Pullis, weil ich nie weiss, was das Wetter wird, nicht weil ich wahnsinnig viele Sachen brauche, sondern weil ich wahnsinnig viele Sachen einpacke, weil ich aus Unwissenheit immer lieber sehr vorsorglich sehr viele Sachen einpacke. Du hingegen gehst voll auf Risiko. Ich gehe auf Risiko, ich habe das mittlerweile aber auch perfektioniert. Ich habe immer, weil ich ja montags komme und bis Mittwoch bleibe, das heißt ich brauche zwei neue Garnituren, das heißt ich habe zwei neue T-Shirts, zwei Socken, zwei Unterhosen, die ich dann in so ein Burrito einrolle, in so ein Podcast-Burrito, könnte man fast sagen. Roll ich den ein und habe dann da genau den Slot. Nein, ich bin da einfach drüber. Und das einfach so, als habe ich den perfekten Slot in meinem Rucksack und kann genau alles mitnehmen. Und dann ist mein Rucksack auch wirklich zum Bersten voll, weswegen ich auch kein Mikrofon oder sowas mitnehmen kann. Zum Bersten voll. Aber jetzt komme ich gerade aus München, weil ich gerade in München war auf einem Junggesellenabschied.
Das heißt, ich musste mir mitnehmen. Wie spricht man in München? Mach das doch mal nach. Jo, servus, grüste, anorat, grüste, mir san aus Minga, so in etwa. Minga? Minga. Das sagen die zu München? München ist Minga, ja. Also sehr weit weg, ist das sehr lächerlich. Das ist ja albern, das ist ja albern, das ist ja völlig albern. Und deswegen hatte ich tatsächlich, weil ich mir dachte, ich fahre in der ersten Klasse nach München, da gibt es eigentlich nichts außer den Jogginghosen-Sandaletten-Look und bin deswegen in Jogginghose gefahren und hat deswegen vergessen, für meine normale Hose einen Gürtel mitzunehmen. Jetzt lebe ich seit vier Tagen ohne Gürtel und es ist furchtbar. Warum auch immer du ohne Gürtel eine Jogginghose tragen kannst, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Nein, aber es ist tatsächlich ein Problem und die Fehler, die du an dem einen Tag machst, jagen dich einfach eine ganze Woche, weil wenn du halt keinen Gürtel mitgenommen hast, du hast keinen anderen Gürtel, auf den du zurückgreifen kannst. Jagen dich noch mehr Fehler, die du noch einen Tag begangen hast, vielleicht noch um ein Leben lang? Ich mache jede Woche einen Fehler, ist so mein Ding, so ein bisschen. Ich versuche jede Woche einen Fehler zu machen. Wie Fahrtfinder, die versuchen jeden Tag eine gute Tat zu begehen. Versuche ich jede Woche einen Fehler zu haben. Was ich immer sage, das Leben ist wie eine Bingo-Karte. Jeder hat dieselben Fehler auf seinem Blatt, aber macht sie in einer anderen Reihenfolge, zu anderen Zeiten. Und es gibt gewisse Dinge, die man einfach... Und am Ende ruft einer Bingo. Und man hat verloren. Und wahrscheinlich ist es jemand anders. Und wer als erstes alle Fehler... Was ist das für eine Lehre? Was kann man jetzt daraus für eine Lehre ziehen? Nein, was ich sagen will, ist, dass wir alle ungefähr das gleiche Leben führen, nur nicht in der gleichen Reihenfolge. Dass wir alle dieselben Erfahrungen machen, aber halt nicht alle zur gleichen Zeit und man trifft halt andere Menschen. Heißt ja, dass jeder theoretisch einen Opfertyp in seinem Freundeskreis haben muss, jeder hat einen coolen Typ in seinem Freundeskreis. Nein, du bist gleichzeitig der Opfertyp und der Tätertyp. Du hast sowohl Opfer- als auch Täter-Segmente auf deiner Bingo-Karte. Also wenn dich jemand vergewaltigt, musst du sagen, okay, ich akzeptiere das, ich toleriere das. Nein, du musst es deswegen nicht tolerieren. Und irgendwann bin ich der Vergewaltiger. Warum fühlen alle Gespräche mit dir immer in diese Richtung? Was machst du denn da? Wie machst du das denn? Ich habe überhaupt nicht von Vergewaltigung angefangen. Hätte mal auf, mich abzulagern hier. Ich sage nur, es ist einfach ein Punkt der Empathie, dass wir wahrscheinlich ähnliche Erfahrungen machen und man mit einem Menschen, der vielleicht ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht hat, schon anders kommunizieren kann, als mit jemandem, der die Erfahrungen noch machen wird, aber das unsere Leben... Ich werde niemals ein Schwert schmieden. Ich glaube, die Leben von Menschen sind alle relativ ähnlich. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Und ich glaube, die werden im Laufe der Zeit immer ähnlicher, weil man immer ähnliche Erfahrungen macht. Du wirst irgendeinen Menschen verlieren, du wirst irgendwie Liebeskummer haben, du wirst selber Liebeskummer streuen, du wirst verschiedene Dinge machen. Und das machst du vielleicht nicht alles gleichzeitig, aber halt irgendwie dann nachher. Und das heißt, wenn wir alle mal richtig alt sind, dann verstehen wir uns richtig gut, weil wir total checken, worum es geht. Weil wir so sagen, ja, ich verstehe dich hundertprozentig. Glaubst du, dass es auch ältere Menschen sich besser verstehen und leichter Freunde finden in ihrem Alterskreis? Ja, ich glaube, die müssen einfach nur, die schieben sich zwei Werte aus Original hin und her und haben damit alles gesagt. Weil alles andere schauen sozusagen hin und nicken sich so, ja, ich verstehe genau, was du meinst. Now we're talking. Ja, ratten wir Gabi und sowas in der Richtung. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, worauf ich hinaus wollte. Aber genau, ich versuche jede Woche einen Fehler zu machen, um meine Bingo-Karte irgendwann komplett abgehakt zu haben, um endlich mit 80-jährigen Menschen zu sprechen zu wollen. Versuchst du die Bingo-Karte, jetzt kann man ja sagen, ich versuche möglichst schnell, möglichst viele Fehler zu begehen, um möglichst schnell Bingo-Geruften zu haben, um dann einen Schritt weiter zu gehen und anfangen Schach zu spielen zum Beispiel. Das ist gut. Hey, das gefällt mir, das gefällt mir, dass du irgendwann ein anderes Spiel spielst, dass du gar nicht mehr Bingo... Ja, aber irgendwann muss... Also sagen wir mal, das ist wie ein Minigolfspiel, du musst erst mal einlochen, bevor du auf die nächste Bahn darfst. Du darfst erst mal Bingo rufen, bevor du weiter gehst. Ja, aber die Frage ist, mit wie vielen Schlägen lochst du ein? Einlochen tut jeder früher oder später. Die Frage ist, wie viele Anläufe brauchst du? Man kann ja auch schnell den Königsweg finden und den Jakobsweg. Den Jakobsweg. Man kann ja auch relativ schnell die richtigen Fehler begehen, um Bingo zu haben. Mit der Ostrade zum Beispiel. Du kannst ja auch, ich finde diese Bingo-Karte immer besser. Also du kannst ja auch relativ schnell die richtigen Fehler machen, um Bingo zu rufen. Und hast dann schon gewonnen. Hast schon gewonnen. Und kannst im nächsten Spiel gehen. Du kannst ja auch manchmal von den Fehlern anderer lernen. Glaubst du, man muss alle Fehler selber begehen? Wenn du sehr viele Freunde hast, die sehr schnell alle Fehler begangen haben. Ich glaube, man muss die Fehler schon selber begehen, man kann aber vielleicht von den Fehlern anderen lernen. Man kann es auch vogeln. Das ist das, wenn der andere sagt, ah, B34, oh, oh, oh, tough luck. Aber du kannst dich natürlich in gewisser Weise auf B34 vorbereiten, aber wenn dann tatsächlich für dich selber B34 kommt, dann hast du... Die Bingo-Metapher ist nicht ganz so gut, weil ja alle dann die gleichen Fehler machen würden, sozusagen, wenn B34 ausgerufen wird, aber jede Zahl heisst ja für jemanden was anderes, ne, also die gleiche Erfahrung kann ja aus anderen Fehlern resultieren und andere Fehler mit sich bringen. So, und ich versuche gerade möglichst viele Fehler zu machen und mein Fehler diese Woche, ich kann ja immer so ein Update halten, Fehler der Woche, und wo ich ihn will, und mein Fehler diese Woche war, wa, wa, wa, wa, wa, dingelingelingeling, der, das, das Podcast-Ufo, der Fehler der Woche, von Fehler, und mein Fehler diese Woche war, mein Gürtel zu Hause zu vergessen, das heisst, ich habe die Woche ohne Gürtel, wie kacke war das denn jetzt, wir hätten das ja vormachen müssen, ja, aber das war auch ein Fehler. Die Welt besteht aus Fehlern. Check! Ja, check it, check it. Was war denn dein Fehler der Woche? Was war dein grösster Fehler der Woche? Ganz kurz, bevor du mich jetzt in diese komische Richtung lenkst. Es ist ja auch so, dass man jetzt dann mit so einer Haltung, dass man Fehler machen muss, leichter mit Fehlern klarkommt. Nee, tatsächlich nicht. Aber es ist... Naja, wenn du sagst, ich muss diesen Fehler gemacht haben und du dir das bewusst machst, dass dieser Fehler lebensnotwendig war, vielleicht sogar. Ja, aber ich sag mal, auch diese Metaperspektive hilft dir ja nicht immer. Also zum Beispiel, dir kann ja irgendwas passieren, zum Beispiel du hast Liebeskummer und du weißt objektiv hundertprozentig, dieser Liebeskummer wird irgendwann aufhören, weil du hast es schon ein paar Mal gemacht, die Erfahrung, aber das ändert an sich nichts an der Situation, weil es ja trotzdem für den Moment genauso schlimm ist. Es ist genau wie wenn du eine Wunde hast, wenn du irgendwie ein Schwert ins Bein gerammt bekommst, weißt du auch, die wird heilen, klar, natürlich, das ist einfach Natur, aber es tut ja trotzdem genauso weh, das heißt, ich glaube, man kann aus Fehlern auch nicht lernen. Mein Fehler der Woche ist in der Tat, ich bin wieder auf eine Marketingmaschinerie reingefallen. Der Fehlkauf der Woche! Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Das würde gerade dir zustimmen. Ich kann auch nicht aus meinen Fehlern lernen, weil ich einfach so angefixt bin von diesen modernen Marketingideen. Ich habe das Magazin Wired abonniert und habe, dann haben die mir Gutscheine mitgeschickt, neben dem Werbegeschenk, kein Witz, Magnetenkugeln.
Der grösste Feind von Stefan Titzel sind auch Gutscheine, da weiss man genau, Troubles growing. Die haben da diese kleinen Visitenkarten, also Gutscheine sehen nicht mehr aus wie Gutscheine, so eklige Papierdrödel, mit Ö muss man immer, es klingt immer lustig, was man sagt, sondern es sind ja jetzt so Visitenkarten-ähnliche Dinge, wo einfach hinten drauf so ein Gutscheincode draufsteht und vorne halt der Wert. Und da waren, die haben dann, wo man das abonniert hat, es kostet irgendwie auch nur 40 Euro für ein Jahr mit geilem Werbegeschenk, Magneten und geilen Gutscheinen, jeweils 20 Euro. Das eine für eine Putzfrau, mega gut.
Für eine Putzfrau?
Ja, also du besitzt...
Kann man das einfach bei irgendeiner Frau einlösen?
Bei jeder Frau, in ihrem wöchentlichen, monatlichen Putzfrauentreffen,
bekommt die dann gesagt, es könnte sein, dass jemand...
Wir haben hier vier eine Umarmungsgutscheine von Florentin Will. Wer muss ran? Wer muss ran? Leute, genau, und einer dieser Gutscheine war halt der Putzfrau Gutschein und der andere war... Ein Podcast. Hello Fresh. Und Hello Fresh ist halt so ein Abo-Dienst für Essensboxen. Und da habe ich mir jetzt eine Essensbox bestellt. Der Nachteil ist aber, die billigste, die man sich da mit diesem Gutschein kaufen kann, kostet 40 Euro. Also habe ich 20 Euro gespart und 20 Euro ausgegeben. Also bin ich bei null rausgekommen. Nein, das stimmt nicht, aber so rede ich mir das ein. Und der kam gerade. Gerade hat ein Kurier angerufen, warum ich wieder nicht zu Hause bin, obwohl ich Essen geliefert bekomme. Eine lebende Ziege, wo soll ich die abliefern? Es riecht in der Essensbox geliefert, was ganz geil ist, weil da sind drei Gerichte drin, und alle Zutaten, die du für die Gerichte brauchst, sind in dieser Box drin. Aber die musst du dann selber noch zubereiten. Du musst selber zubereiten. Was ist für ein Aufwandslevel? Ich glaube, es ist völlig einfach. Ich werde euch mal kochen und werde euch dann berichten, wie es läuft. Da ich noch nie gekocht habe oder auch noch annähernd irgendwie Fähigkeiten besitze, die was mit Essen zu tun haben. Ich kann Rührei machen und ich kann nur den Spiegelei machen und das war schon. Aber wenn ich das gekocht bekomme, dann werde ich es meiner Folge mit euch kochen vielleicht. Ja, das finde ich doch für einen Fehler jetzt nicht so schlecht. Ja gut, da sind 20 Euro halt für was rausgehauen, was ich vielleicht einfach, ich werde die Zutaten separat essen und in meinem Mund zubereiten. Und auch nur die Hälfte der Zutaten verwenden, weil man einfach sau faul ist. Schneiden Sie jetzt noch eine Avocado auf und ne, fuck it. Öffnen Sie das Paket. Nope, not gonna happen. Aber tatsächlich wird sich ja unser Leben wahrscheinlich bald massgeblich ändern, weil... Wenn wir zusammenziehen. Eventuell ziehen wir tatsächlich zusammen. Ich möchte nach Köln ziehen und Stefan hat mir angeboten in seinem bett zu wohnen aber tatsächlich könnte sich unsere wohnungssuche relativ schnell beenden denn stefan titze hat diese woche gefolgt eine wohnung die direkt hier an unserem arbeitsplatz ist nein und du hast einen wettbewerb entdeckt wo man tatsächlich ein haus gewinnen kann für 200 dollar sehr gut und das ist tatsächlich eine sehr die Überleitung der Woche. Das ist tatsächlich... Ja, ich versuch's dir auch schon das vierte Mal zu machen. Und zwar ist das Konzept sehr einfach... Das ist auch so eigentlich bei uns, wenn einer was Gutes macht, dass die andere dann einfach nachher noch wieder auf den Boden der Tatsache zurückholt. In diesem Podcast werden keine guten Überleitungen stattfinden. Nein. Also die Idee ist folgendes, es gibt in Amerika ein Haus, eine Villa, die irgendwo an einem Fluss oder total geile Lage, super geiles Haus. Und dieses Haus soll verkauft werden und anscheinend gibt es diesen Immobilientrick. Es ist eine Villa, alles aus Holz, mega geiles Wohnzimmer, du kannst von deinem Wohnzimmer, ist das Glas verdeckt, kannst auf Wasser gucken, du bist in so einem geilen Fluss, das ist einfach so wie die Idylle, wie der Himmel auf Erden eines Hauses.
Es ist ein super tolles Haus und das soll verkauft werden. Und zwar die Idee ist, damit die Verkäufer sicher gehen, dass es zu einem gewissen Mindestpreis verkauft wird, hatten sie folgende Idee. Und zwar verkaufen sie dieses Haus für 200 Dollar, aber sie wählen den Käufer aus einem riesigen Pool von Leuten aus, die sich bewerben bei ihnen, und jeder dieser Bewerber zahlt 200 Dollar. Und wenn mindestens, glaube ich, 2000 Leute oder so sich bewerben, wird einer dieser Personen ausgewählt, der kriegt das Haus für 200 Dollar. Das heißt, der Käufer zahlt nur 200 Dollar, die Verkäufer kriegen aber insgesamt mindestens 400.000 Dollar, weil sie von ganz vielen Leuten Geld bekommen, allerdings kriegt nur einer das Haus. Das heisst, es ist so eine Art Lotterie. Du zahlst ein und kriegst dann sozusagen den Wert von anderen Leuten. Das ist ein bisschen ein Crowdfunding, die schon aber ein paar Formen des Gewinnspiels ist. Und natürlich als psychologischer Effekt obendrauf, weil man wahrscheinlich nicht gern drum wetten würde, haben sie eben gesagt, wir machen es nicht zufällig, wählen wir aus den Interessenten jemanden aus, sondern jeder soll eben einen 200 Wörter langen Essay schreiben, warum genau er dieses Haus haben darf.
Jetzt ist da sofort mein Bullshit-Detektor angegangen, wo ich mir dachte...
Ich habe diesen Link geschickt und war mega euphorisiert mal wieder.
Bei mir sind diese Marketing-Maschinerie zusammengegangen.
Die Fehlkaufs-Napsen haben wieder angefangen zu feuern.
Das ist ein sehr ausgebautes Gehirnteil von mir, was halt gefeuert hat und direkt den Link geschickt hat. Ich habe nicht verstanden, was du daran auszusetzen hattest im ersten Moment. Für mich ging da erstmal sofort die Betrugslampe an, so von wegen, das ist einfach nur ein Gag, sozusagen, dass du garantierst, dass möglich ist. Es war relativ präsent auf der Bild-Zeitung Startseite. Ach, da kann es ja nicht schlecht sein, sag ich mal. Und im Endeffekt stehen keine Lügen. Ich dachte mir, die werden sich wahrscheinlich nicht 5000 Essays durchlesen und tatsächlich... Stimmt, das war deine Antwort. Die haben dann geschrieben... Eine ziemlich schlechte Antwort auf eine sehr geile Sache. Ja, ich versuchte... Die werden nicht alle lesen. Schau mal, die haben da auf ihrer Seite, sie haben so eine Jury von irgendwie Literaturprofessoren oder von irgendeiner Universität, die sich die alle durchlesen und es auswählen. Genau. Aber das Interesse dahinter ist natürlich rein finanziell. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie wirklich sagen, wir geben dieses Haus an jemanden weiter, der da irgendein emotionales Bedürfnis dafür hat, sondern wir machen das einfach durch dieses Lotteriegedanken, damit wir einen gewissen Mindestverkaufswert garantiert haben. Weil wenn weniger als, glaube ich, 2000 Menschen einsenden, wird dieses Haus überhaupt nicht verkauft und du kriegst dann 200 Dollar zurück. Das heisst, du musst 200 Dollar zahlen und ein Essay schreiben und hast die Möglichkeit, für 200 Dollar ein richtig geiles Haus zu bekommen.
Das ist natürlich der Stoff, aus dem Legenden gemacht sind, wo man sich denkt, geil, das wäre mal ein Riesenteil.
Allein, was wäre das für eine Folge, wenn wir alles eingerichtet haben und an so einem See...
Ja?
Was hast du getan jetzt?
Ich habe den Link geöffnet.
Aber auch mit dem Wort Alter. Aber was wäre das für eine geile Folge, wenn wir plötzlich da in ein neues Haus eingezogen sind und aufnehmen, einfach in einem neuen Haus, wie wir gerade in einem geilsten Haus der Welt eingezogen sind. Ja, aber das ist doch immer so diese Sache bei diesen Gewinnspieldingern. Man denkt sich immer, irgendjemand kriegt's doch. Und warum soll ich nicht der sein, der es kriegt? Warum soll es irgend so ein Dödel bekommen und nicht ich? Ich habe genau die gleiche Chance wie so ein Dödel. Und wenn ich nicht machen würde, würde ich dem Dödel ermöglichen, dass der dieses geile Haus kriegt und ich kriege es nicht. Im Umkehrschluss, je weniger von euch, alle die bei euch nicht teilnehmen, wollen, dass ein anderer das bekommt. Ja, richtig. Und haben keinen Bock darauf, es selber zu bekommen. Das heißt im Umkehrschluss. Das ist egoistisch. Nicht bei der Lotterie mitzumachen, nicht bei Lotto-Toto mitzumachen, ist einfach wahnsinnig empathisch und eigentlich uncool, weil man will das andere gewinnen, offensichtlich. Absolut. Absolut. Und ich habe mir natürlich sofort gedacht, welchen ... This episode is brought to you by Lotto. Muss man 200 Euro zahlen, Dollar zahlen, um mitzumachen? Um mitzumachen. Du zahlst 200 Euro und schickst diesen Essay. Wie uncut ist das denn? Ja, aber das ist doch die Idee hinter der ganzen Sache. Shit, ich habe das nicht verstanden. Ne, ne, ne, du musst tatsächlich 200 Dollar zahlen, auch der, der es am Ende nicht bekommt. Das heißt, der sehr, sehr grosse Grossteil zahlt einfach Geld für gar nichts. Ach, sehr viel Geld für gar nichts? Ja! Ich habe das nicht so verstanden, dass man das... Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, das ist halt Lottospiel, ne? Für eine Villa kriegst du... Das sind diese Dinge, die ich dann immer nicht mitbekomme bei sowas. Auch ich habe gestern eine Naschi-Bierne probiert. Und auch das Kleingedruckte. Schmeckt nicht. Ja, habe ich nicht gelesen. Ja, sorry. Genau, genau das, was ich sagen wollte. Aber interessant, wir denken schon an den gleichen Pointen. Ja. Auch nicht gut. Okay. Aber tatsächlich ist es so ein Punkt, weil bei mich hat dieses Projekt total getroffen, weil ich mir dachte, mit diesem Essay, da kann man dann was total Emotionales schreiben, so ich verdiene dieses Haus, weil und man schreibt da total gut und baut da total viele Gags ein.
Man kann auch drinschreiben, ich bin mit dir verwandt, entfernt und dein Vater hat bei seinem Tod gesagt, gib doch Stefan Tietze und Florentin Will das Haus. Man kann die auch mega emotional unter Druck setzen. Oder wenn du das Haus nicht gibst, werden deine Kinder sterben. Einen qualvollen Tod. Ja, genau. Oder zum Beispiel, also diese Juroren sind vom Hanover College, wo ich dann dachte, auch dann so baut man so ein paar Gags. Hannover, sag ruhig Hannover. Wo ich mir dann auch dachte, da kann man gut ein paar Gags einbauen. Irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, meine Zukunft sieht so schlecht aus wie das Hanover College oder irgendwie sowas, so Augenzwinkern, die Juroren loben oder haten. Wo ich auch einen Zwickersmiley reinmache, warum denn mich? Du, du hast 200 Wörter, zählt ein Zwickersmiley als Wort? Nein, ich glaube nicht. Und deswegen dachte ich, aber das sind so Dinger, wo ich immer drauf reinfalle, weil es so, also ich sag mal, ich falle oft in solche Fallen rein, wo ich mir denke, der Zuschauer wäre auf meiner Seite. Wenn mein Leben Film wäre und ich würde diesen Essay schreiben und vielleicht ist es sogar so ein bisschen wie in diesem Film mit dem Blackjack-Spieler, 21, dass du am Anfang sitzt er in seinem Stipendiumsding und sagt, warum verdienen sie dieses Stipendium.
Und dann geht der ganze Film los und dann wird die Geschichte erzählt, wie er nach Las Vegas gefahren ist, wie er Leute kennengelernt hat, wie er gepokert hat, wie wahnsinnig alles verloren hat. Und am Ende des Films siehst du wieder ihn, wie er das Stipendium sagt und sozusagen, das hat er gerade alles erzählt für und dann kriegt er das Stipendium. Das heißt, es ist so eine klasse Hollywood-Situation. Oder der Film Die Verurteilten, wo Martin, Morgan Freeman immer da reinkommt in diesen Raum, wo halt die so Leute sitzen in dem Komitee und entscheiden müssen, ob er entlassen werden kann endlich oder nicht. Und er immer wieder zurückgeschickt wird und am Ende halt diese mega emotionale, zweimal wieder zurückgeschickt und am dritten Mal erzählt er so eine emotionale Geschichte. Ich bin nicht vollständig sozialisiert. Ich bin noch nicht reif dafür. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was mich draußen erwartet, aber ich bin jetzt schon so lange drin, was soll ich noch machen, was soll mir noch passieren und die ihn dann daraufhin rauslassen und dein Problem ist halt, dass du wahrscheinlich nur an deine Position denkst, aber das sind ja andere Menschen, die über dich entscheiden. Ja, aber die 400 anderen Insassen, deren Geschichte nicht verfilmt wurde, haben das ja genauso gemacht. Oder die hätten doch einfach das Nein sagen können.
Und es wäre der traurigste Film der Welt gewesen.
Aber das klingt für mich wie ein Hollywoodfilm.
Der kleine, fette Junge, der irgendwie nach Köln ziehen will in die grosse, weite Welt
und dann so ein Ding hat.
Du musst jetzt ein gammeliges Scheisse aus, weil es gar nicht so cool ist.
Mit Stefan Titzer, der Erzfeind,
der aufgebaut wird.
Du wirst sofort gezeigt, neben dem kleinen Mädchen-Ohrfeig.
So wirst du eingeführt. In so einer Narbe auch. Und das ist die Situation, wo ich mir denke, da könnte man einen coolen Film drum machen. Ich sitze vor diesem leeren Blatt und schreibe mein Essay, und dann passiert mir irgendwas Tolles, ich gehe auf große Abenteuer. Das finde ich aber geil bei Filmen, wenn die so anfangen würden, wie man es erwartet, aber halt nicht so weiter wie man es erwartet. Also wirklich so eine sehr emotionale, auch dann kommt im Hintergrund so eine Klaviermusik plötzlich und dann kommen die Geigen dazu, man denkt, okay, okay, er schreibt mehr und es wird immer emotionaler und so. Und am Ende hat er nur einen großen Penis gemalt. Er bekommt es einfach nicht, er hat einen grossen Smiley gemalt und ist vorbei. Aber das ist tatsächlich so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, der Zuschauer wäre auf meiner Seite. Wenn mein Leben jetzt gerade ein Film wäre, wäre der Zuschauer auf meiner Seite und denke mir, irgendwie muss man doch recht haben, weil ich schon in so einer kosmischen Narrative denke und mir denke, ich verdiene es, dieses Haus zu kriegen, also kann ich es auch kriegen.
So, wenn du nur dafür kämpfst, was du liebst und was du wirklich willst, kannst du es auch schaffen. Und das ist ja genau der Impuls, auf den die ja bauen, dass wenn du nur eine wahnsinnig ehrliche und nackte und authentische Essay schreibst, dann kriegst du das auf jeden Fall. Und damit zapfen diese genau diese urmenschliche Narrativsucht an. Dass man selber in der Hand hat, das zu schaffen. Was man letztendlich natürlich nicht hat und was wir wahrscheinlich auch einfach random auswerten. Aber dieser emotionale Trigger ist halt einfach da, zu sagen, ich schaff das schon. Gut, haben wir verstanden. Jetzt hast du was gefunden.
Und zwar hast du den Gewinnerbeitrag einer ähnlichen Ausschreibe
gefunden, von vor ein paar Jahren,
wo wir jetzt mal ganz gespannt sind alle.
Wir sitzen uns jetzt mal emotional
zusammen, wir Hörer
und ich, und
das ist mal ein Schneideres vor dir und sind ganz gespannt.
Genau, was Ähnliches wurde
nämlich auch schon mal gemacht für Lovell Inn, hieß dieses Haus, diese Villa, die verkauft wurde.
Und man denkt es natürlich, geil, das muss jetzt der Monster-Text gewesen sein, der aus mindestens 2000 Einsendungen ausgewählt wurde.
Was ist die Geschichte, was ist da dahinter? Und das ist die Geschichte.
Es sind sehr viele, sehr schwierige englische Worte drin, muss ich ganz mal voraussagen.
Der Text ist auch französisch, ich weiß nicht genau. Das ist tatsächlich sehr viele Satzzeilen. Ich lese nur den ersten Abschnitt vor. There are very many very difficult English words. I have to say that. The text is also French.
I really know that there are many sentences.
I'll just read the first one.
Can we maybe have music?
No.
Maybe in the Post-Portution?
No problem. we embarked on the journey of painstakingly converting a delapidated building into a charming guesthouse and restaurant. We were newly married and learned important lessons that both solidified our relationship and allowed us to have a thriving business in the process. A successful marriage requires passion, hospitality and commitment. Perhaps the same is true for this venture. Hospitality is more than good manners, proper etiquette, great food and a comfortable room. It is also about being consistent, keeping pace with customers' demands and taking good care of the staff. However, the welfare of a marriage is always of paramount importance. My wife is the talented chef with a culinary degree, catering and restaurant management experience. I have marketing, inkeeping, bartending and handyman skills. Our teamwork earned a several TripAdvisor Certificate of Excellences and top people's choice, accolades, including best chef, best gourmet dining and best bartending. This contest is fortuitous since we now aspire to finally own a place outright,
somewhere to share our love of fine food, great wines and entertaining with others.
Undoubtedly our passion, hospitality and commitment is the perfect recipe for a successful marriage to the beautiful center, love inn and restaurant. Das ist nämlich genau das, wo ich erwarte, dass es die Mehrheit schickt. Nämlich so eine herzerweichende, sehr, sehr, wir verkörpern das Gutmenschentum und haben es verdient, in diesem Haus zu wohnen. Ja, aber auch dieser lame Move, wir setzen jetzt gegenüber eine erfolgreiche Beziehung und ein erfolgreiches Restaurant und die sind sich ja total ähnlich, weil es geht nene nene und nene. Schnitt, sie sind geschieden und haben sich fast totgegrügelt.
But the food is always good.
Ja, das ist nämlich genau das, wo ich denke,
die Mehrheit schreibt solche Texte,
weil sie denken, das kommt an, aber dass
auch solche Leute das dann ausfählen,
auch noch solchen Leuten dann noch so ein Essen hinwerfen,
indem sie das auch noch... Und nur weil die ein paar
Futterhörer können, wie Fortucious
oder Fortages oder wie auch immer,
verdammt nochmal, das kriegen wir nicht hin. Wir haben keine guten Wertungen auf TripAdvisor, wir haben gar nichts. Aber wir haben gute Wertungen auf iTunes. Aber trotzdem würde ich sagen, wir schreiben da einen fucking Text verdammt nochmal. Sehr gut. Wenn du etwas liebst, dann musst du dafür kämpfen und musst alles geben und musst sein Innerstes nach außen gehen.
Wenn du ein Haus so sehr begehrst, dann ist es das Haus. Und ein Haus ist genauso wie eine gute Freundschaft. Es braucht ein starkes Fundament, harte Wände und auch bei dem grössten Wind darf es nicht einknicken. Und wenn es mal reinregnet, wenn mal der Wind gegen das Fenster peitscht, dann darfst du nicht aufgeben. Es ist nämlich dein Haus, es ist dein Projekt, es ist dein Leben. Und auch wenn im Keller Wasser ist, dann nimmst du den Eimer und eimerst den Keller leer. Und wenn du Ameisen hast und Kakerlaken und meinetwegen auch die Ratten, die auf deinem Boden herumkriechen, ist das kein Grund aufzugeben, was du dir bei einem Gewinnspiel fragwürdig erspielt hast. Und wenn die Nachbarskatze kommt und zu dir ins Haus will und du sie füttern willst, dann tust du es nicht, weil es verdammt asozial ist, anderen Leuten mit deiner Zuneigung und deiner Liebe die Katze zu klauen. Und wenn das Haus im Unterhalt nachher so viel kostet, dass du dann unter der Brücke schlafen müsstest eigentlich und anschaffen gehen musst und mit dem frackwilgen Freund, mit dem er für einen Podcast was gemacht hat, einfach nicht mehr klarkommen, sondern das Leben vor die Hunde geht, dann muss es trotzdem noch durchziehen. Und wenn du überhaupt kein Interesse hast, in den USA den Rest seines Lebens zu verbringen und dieses Haus wahrscheinlich nie benutzen wirst und es nur als coolen Insider für deinen erfolglosen Podcast nutzen wirst, trotzdem! Wenn du es nur für den Gag machst und wenn du es nur dafür machst, um irgendwann mal eine gute Geschichte zu erzählen zu haben, dann brenne es halt nieder. Tu es für den Gag! Tu es für den Gag! Für den Kick, für den Augenblick! Zwei Menschen haben im Haus gewonnen und haben es dann niedergebrannt. Wie lustig wäre das denn bitte? Ja! Ja! Verdammt nochmal! Wir schreiben jetzt diesen Text, verdammt!
Okay, also...
Sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, mein Name ist Florian Will, ich liebe lange Spaziergänge am Strand und Chips mit Speckgeschmack.
Und meine Hobbys sind Freundentreffen und in Freundes wieder schreiben.
Ich wollte mich erkundigen, wie gut die Internetverbindung in ihrem Haus ist.
Ich würde es weitestgehend dafür nutzen, dass ich mich im Keller einschliesse und eine Woche lang nicht rauskam.
Lass uns vielleicht auch so etwas schreiben. Wir wissen ja jetzt genau, in welche Richtung Gewinnertexte gehen müssen.
Wir brauchen Metaphern.
Florentin und ich sind seit mehreren Jahren.
Du musst jetzt nicht wirklich mitschreiben. Wir machen das nur für den Gag. Ja, wir können es ja transkribieren. Was ist ein Haus? Ein Haus ist nicht nur eine Ansammlung von Bausteinen, Holz, Stein, Termiten, Asbest und Kabelleitungen. Ein Haus ist mehr als das. Ein Haus ist ein Fundament. Ein Haus ist Heimat. Was heißt das eigentlich, Heimat? Heißt das nur, dass dein iPhone sich automatisch ins WLAN einklingt? Heißt das nur, dass du den widerlichen Geruch nicht mehr riechst, den deine Freunde jedes Mal riechen, wenn sie vorbeikommen und sich denken, Alter, wo lebst du eigentlich? Hast du schon wieder die Chips in der Ecke stehen lassen? Ja, was ist das? Ist das ein Eimer Schaumwaffeln da? Warum hast du den noch? Den gab es vor drei Monaten bei Lidl im Angebot, mittlerweile nicht mehr. Was ist Heimat noch? Ist es der, wir haben 200 Zeichen schon komplett. Heimat heisst ankommen. Heimat heisst, an einem Ort zu leben, wo du sein kannst, wer du wirklich bist, wo du dich nicht verstellen musst. Eine Art zweite Haut. Heimat heisst auch Neuanfang. Es heisst auch Umkrempeln, Neuanfang. Ein Ruhepol, an dem du dich zurückkehren kannst, nach dem grossen Abenteuer, vor dem grossen Abenteuer. Wie ein warmer Pulli, den du dir anziehst, wenn du dich gedanklich verbunden fühlst. Womit? Man hat niemals so eine emotionale, anfeuernde Rede und jemand so, womit verboten. Was meinen Sie? Genau das ist nämlich, wenn man diesen Film auch mal einhaken würde. Ja, genau so. Was meinst du damit eigentlich? What? Pardon? Sorry? What did you just say? What do you mean, freedom? Braveheart, freedom. I mean, freedom is a sehr vage Term. Was meinst du, freedom?
Ich meine, für die Scots-Leute, freedom ist uns entschuldig.
Shouldn't we take their freedom of enschuldig?
Der Moment, an dem das Podcast UFO plötzlich englisch gesprochen hat.
Das ist nicht gut funktionieren.
Das ist, was wir eben so in Rage gesprochen haben.
Also diesen Text einfach transkribieren und dahin schicken.
Und 200 Euro einfach nicht.
Lass mal versuchen, dass...
Doch, wir müssen schon 200 Dollar zahlen.
Wie geil wäre das denn? Stell dir vor, wir kriegen dieses fucking Haus. Dann machen wir einen eigenen motherfucking Humor-Kongress. Wo ist das Haus eigentlich? Ist das überhaupt wirklich? Ich glaube, wir haben auch gar nicht mehr so viel Zeit. Ich glaube, das ist sogar schon vorbei. Ne, bis zum 31. Oktober, bis Halloween. Ich glaube, wir haben noch zehn Tage oder so. Aber wir kriegen das hin. Wir machen das und once again, wir richten unsere Bitten an euch, uns vielleicht bei PayPal zu unterstützen. Wie gut das wäre, mit 200 Dollar. 200 Dollar brauchen wir dringend. Ich habe immer die Hoffnung, dass wir einen reichen Hörer haben, der irgendwann mal denkt, fuck it, ich überweise ihn einfach 100.000 Euro, ist mir egal. Aber ich habe es ja. Genau wie ich mir immer denke, ich war einmal in meinem Leben Casino, auch bei einer Klassenfahrt, habe ich auch schon mal erzählt, glaube ich, wir haben immer Rollet gespielt und ich immer einen Euro auf Rot oder Schwarz gesetzt, sauarmselig. Und der Dealer schon so, okay, geh, geh, alle waren im Anzug, ich war im Pulli da, haben immer einen Euro auf Rot gesetzt und neben mir war halt immer dieser Typ, der keine Chips mehr hatte, sondern diese Karten, wo irgendwie auch so 1000 Euro drauf waren plötzlich. So grosse Karten, HelloFresh. Ein Gutschein für eine Umarmung auf Rot. Eine Foodbox. Und einfach so grosse Karten hatte, wo ich maximal viel Geld, die man auf eine Zahl gelegt hat. Ein Euro auf Rot, null Risiko, null Geld, er maximal Risiko mit maximal viel Geld einfach drauflegt und plötzlich gewonnen hat, ne, und das war natürlich auch schwarz, ich habe meinen Euro verloren und er hat irgendwie das zweiunddreissigfache auf seine scheisse Sechzehnder bekommen. Und da denke ich mir auch mal so, warum gibt der mir dann nicht einfach mal Geld, weil ich vielleicht netter Typ bin und mit mir rede und vielleicht findet er mich sympathisch und gibt mir halt Geld, weil so ein Typ kann einfach sehr leicht Leute glücklich machen, mit sehr viel Geld. Es kann tatsächlich passieren. Mein Bruder ist Schuhverkäufer und der hat oft sehr reiche Gäste, die da so vorbeikommen, teilweise Russen oder auch Araber, die wahnsinnig viel Geld haben. Und die schmeissen halt einfach mit Geld um sich. Die zeigen dann halt einfach irgendwie Schuhe und nehmen die mit. Und er als Verkäufer kriegt dann auch ein Trinkgeld und die greifen einfach in die Hosentasche und packen einfach an Geld, was da ist, und geben es dem, ohne anzuschauen. Du könntest Glück haben, und es sind halt irgendwie drei, fünfhundert Euro Scheine oder halt irgendwas Kleines. Die kennen den Wert von diesem Papier gar nicht. Es kann halt einfach wahnsinnig, du kannst ja Glück haben und wahnsinnig viel kriegen. Und ich habe am Wochenende mit einer... Kannst du auch Pech haben, dass sie zu wenig gegeben haben. Sorry. Ich habe mich dann am Wochenende mit einer Prostituierten unterhalten und die meinte auch, es konnte tatsächlich vorkommen, dass du wirklich dein gesamtes Vermögen, das du brauchst, an einem einzigen Abend mit einem einzigen Mann verdienst, wo du vorher irgendwie jahrelang rumgerödelt hast für nichts, wenn du halt einmal den richtigen Typen triffst, der den Club betritt, dann hast du es geschafft und den kannst du verführen. Das finde ich sehr interessant, ein interessanter Gedanke. Aber lass uns mal kurz zu dem Satz zurückkommen, den du eben gesagt hast. Du hast am Wochenende mit einer Prostituierten geschlafen? Habe ich noch richtig verstanden. Ich habe, sag ich mal, also ich habe für eine halbe Stunde bezahlt und wir waren dann relativ schnell durch. Wir haben nur geredet. Wir haben dann schon recht viel geredet und irgendwie habe ich noch ein paar Tatschritte gezahlt. Wir haben nur emotional geredet. Ja, genau. Aber so was erzählt. Und nee, tatsächlich war es tatsächlich sehr interessant. Die hat mich tatsächlich knallhart einfach für einen zivilen Polizisten gehalten und dachte, ich würde sie jetzt ausfragen von wegen Menschenhandel, weil das halt tatsächlich ein echtes Problem ist.
Und ich habe sie auch gefragt, ob sie
Menschen gehandelt wurde und was sie
Menschenänder finden.
Nein, sie etwa?
Hast du die auch gesiezt?
Ich habe sie auch gesiezt, ja klar. Das ist auch schon
komisch für die, glaube ich. Für die vor allem.
Ja, weiss nicht, vor allem, ich fand es interessant,
weil die tatsächlich halt immer in diesem
Arbeitsmodus drin sind, halt so, hey, vor allem, also was mich echt irritiert hat, also ich war Arbeit, ist das doch Arbeit? Kann man Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, dasiss nicht, vor allem, ich fand es interessant, weil die tatsächlich halt immer in diesem Arbeitsmodus drin sind, halt so, ey, vor allem, also was mich echt irritiert hat, also ich war...
Arbeit, ist das doch Arbeit, kann man sagen?
Ja, aber was tatsächlich mich irritiert hat, dass die wirklich, also man denkt ja, Prostituierte bewegen sich im Feld der Erotik, ja, die verstehen Erotik, also sag ich mal, welche Reize zeigt man, welche Reize zeigt man nicht, wie flirtet man, wie verführt man, und deswegen hat es mich sehr irritiert, wie unglaublich plump die waren. Also wenn ich so, hier Ficken, Blasen, Anahe hier so, kommen die ran, denkst du so, what the fuck, also so halt funktioniert diese Technik, wo man sich denkt so, eigentlich ist es ja, weißt du, du bist als... Aber wer geht denn da hin, Leute, die mit dem Selbstwertgefühl halt gegen Null streben und Leute, die halt auch wirklich dann nur das... Die sollen aber die wollen ja Selbstwertgefühl bekommen. Die werden ja den ganzen Tag irgendwie abgelehnt und haben irgendwie keinen Erfolg. Deswegen wollen sie ja da vielleicht mal eine Frau haben, die auf sie zugeht und mit ihnen redet und mit ihnen flirtet und sowas. Das, was sie halt sonst nicht kennen. Und weil die können halt auch auf einen billigen Straßenstrich gehen und sich da jemanden holen. Und es war ein gehobenes Etablissement, also möchte ich nur sagen... Echt jetzt? Ach so. Ja. Das erinnert ja alles einfach. Ja, wo ich mir dann auch dachte, okay, selbst da ist es zu billig. Aber es ist tatsächlich auch sehr schwierig mit dem ... Ah, Sherlock Tietze hat gerade knallhart was zusammengeschlossen. Du hast eben erzählt, dass du auf einem Junggesellenabschied warst. Aber man darf nicht erzählen, was auf einem Junggesellenabschied passiert ist. Und du hast mit seiner Prostituierten gesprochen. Ich bin sehr interessant ... Und es war auch verdammt teuer, mit der zu sprechen. Also sie kann es ehrlich sagen, ich habe da eine Menge Geld verloren. Aber mich hat es tatsächlich auch gewundert, wie wenig normal man mit diesen Leuten reden kann. Dass sie halt immer in diesem Flirty-Ich-will-dir-was-verkaufen-Modus sind. Hä, mit meiner Mutter konnte ich mal ganz gut reden. Bo, bo, bo! Bam, Comedy! Ja, und ich habe mich immer daran halten, weil ich halt irgendwie wissen wollte, einfach wie das funktioniert, weil es ist auch nicht so ganz transparent. Es ist so, ich dachte, da steht dann irgendwie an der Wand so hier, was kostet was, so ganz knallhart, weil du musst ja wissen, was Sache ist. Wie so eine Getränkekarte. Ja, weil du musst ja wissen, was Sache ist, um es einkaufen zu können. Du kannst ja dann, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Teil des Deals. Wie diese sehr teure Restaurants, wo die Preise auch nicht mehr draufstehen. Ja. Wenn Preise nicht mehr draufstehen, erkennst du, ob es gut ist oder nicht.
Ja, und ich wollte zum Beispiel fragen, was ist das Billigste, was man kaufen kann?
Also kann ich für 30 Cent eine Umarmung kaufen?
Also mich.
Hat Frau Titzel gesagt, mich, ja.
Also kann man sich eine Umarmung kaufen für 50 Cent oder so?
Was ist das absolut Billigste und was kostet schon was? Also wenn ich sie jetzt einfach umarmen würde, würde das schon was kosten?
Also wie funktioniert das?
Aber es funktioniert tatsächlich nicht so. Sie meinte, dass man sich tatsächlich eher Zeiten kauft und dann in der Zeit machen kann, was man will. So in der Richtung. Und das gar nicht so einzelpreismäßig funktioniert. Allerdings hat mir eine andere an dem Abend gesagt, dass es anders funktioniert. Also anscheinend gibt es da auch keine so allgemeine Preise. Es war eine wilde Nacht. Es war eine crazy Nacht. Ich glaube, ich habe an dem Abend noch nie mit so vielen Frauen gesprochen wie an diesem diesem abend also huiuiui sag ich mal hallöchen nee aber ja das war der zweite Fehler glaube ich diese woche interessant ich glaube ist noch durch ne ja liebe Leute mit dieser Knallanekdote. Oh Mann, jetzt stehe ich hier in der runtergelassene Hose da. Irgendwie habe 160 Euro gezahlt irgendwie. Du, ich bin auch wieder, das ist so ein Feld, wo ich auch gar nicht mit klarkomme. Ich war auch immer in Berlin, da kennst du dich aus, aber ich weiß nicht genau, Ecke Friedrichstrasse. Ja, ja, ja. Da ist da ist auch so ein Strassenstrich, wo auch wirklich aber auch Edelnutten, wie man dazu sagt, glaube ich, weiss ich auch nicht, stehen dann da rum und sprechen dann auch an. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch ein edleres Etablissement, es ist eine Strasse, aber es ist, glaube ich, eine edle Strasse, ein edles Etablissement, zu dem die halt gehören. Und da habe ich auch mal ein bisschen mit einer Prostituin gesprochen. Und das ist schon ganz interessant, wenn man selber auch immer die ganze Zeit denkt, also tun die einem leid oder machen die das wirklich, weil sie Bock darauf haben? Das ist natürlich die essentielle Frage, was natürlich auch stark mit der Anziehungskraft zusammenhängt. Meistens reden die sich ja auch selber schön und sagen, gut, ich mache das ja so. Und man sagt, gut, die tun mir nicht leid, weil die haben sich offensichtlich für diesen Weg entschieden. Auf der anderen Seite kann man aber auch sagen, gut, die wissen ja nicht, was sie besser finden würden, weil sie haben ja noch keinen, sie haben anscheinend keinen anderen Job. Also vielleicht wären sie eine sehr glückliche Schuhverkäuferin. Ja, das kann schon sein und ich habe sie auch gefragt, wie lange sie das noch machen will will. Also ich frage mich, ob die Frauen, die das machen, ich gehe immer davon aus, dass sie konstant denken, so schnell wie es geht raus hier, so schnell wie es geht. Ich will einfach nur eine gewisse Summe zusammenkriegen, ich will den einen Macker, den einen Millionär angeln, der gibt mir wahnsinnig viel oder am bestenfalls holt er mich hier raus irgendwie und dann bin ich raus. Oder ich weiss nicht, vielleicht gibt es auch Prostituierten, die in den Business sind und dann halt sagen so von wegen, ja, das ist mein Business und ich will da die Beste der Welt werden.
Ich habe es auch unterostituierten, die in den Business sind und dann halt sagen, so von wegen, ja, das ist mein Business und ich will da die Beste der Welt werden. Ich habe jetzt auch einen Tabanlashop aufgemacht, also ein bisschen so mit dem Kliketsdenken. Ich habe eine Facebook-Seite und sowas in der Richtung. Aber meinte sie auch so von wegen, ja, ich weiß nicht, morgen oder nächste Woche oder nächsten Monat. Also sie meinte, hat schon durchklingen lassen, so dass das halt nicht so ein Ding ist. Wo ich mir auch denke, wie respektlos ist es eigentlich, eine Prostituierte zu fragen, wie lange sie das noch machen will. Weil man ja natürlich automatisch impliziert, dass sie einen richtig beschissenen Job hat. Was sie ja tatsächlich auch hat. Aber kann man ihr das so ins Gesicht nehmen? Weil ich meine, die arme Frau, die arbeitet gerade, die hat noch eine fucking Sechsstundenschicht vor sich und da kommt irgend so ein Scheissdepp zu ihr und sagt, sag mal, du hast schon einen richtig Scheissjob, oder? Also das ist wirklich, da haben wir im Nachhinein auch echt Gedanken gemacht, so von wegen, eigentlich ist es schon sehr respektlos. Ja, nee. Aber ich meine, die wird sich das ja wahrscheinlich auch selber ständig denken und die wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht immer mit dem Messen gefühlt. Auf der anderen Seite geht es auch zum Comedian hin und sagt, du hast ja schon einen ganz geilen Job. Ja gut, aber das ist was anderes, weil der einen geilen Job hat. Ja, nein, also Comedian ist ja auch viel kaputt im Kopf. So, also man kann ja immer ... Ja, aber das ist was komplett anderes, als wenn wir zu einer Falle, ey, dein Job ist so fucking beschissen, dass ich dich deswegen ausfahre. Du bist nur deswegen interessant, weil du einen scheiß Job hast. Du gehst erst mal per se davon aus, dass der Job ... Du klassifizierst erst mal, mit deinen Gedankengängen steckst du die Jobs in Schubladen. Gut oder schlecht. Ja, klar. Das ist beides mal falsch. Beides mal ist der Job des Comedians nicht mega geil und mega entspannt und mega krass easy zu leben. Auf der einen Seite ist das aber auch nicht der schlechteste Job.
sondern ja ich meine ich habe ja auch generell nichts gegen prostitution aber ich denke ist es vielleicht einfach ein scheiß move wenn halt wenn du einen job hast und leute den ganzen
tag zu dir hinkommen und sagen dein job ist richtig scheisse so das ist dann auch so selbst
wenn du einen job gerne machst fühlst du dich ja schlecht weil du immer denkst durch den augen
der anderen bin ich halt total nichts wert irgendwie und total einen Job hast und Leute den ganzen Tag zu dir hinkommen und sagen, dein Job ist richtig scheiße. Das ist dann auch so, selbst wenn du einen Job gerne machst, fühlst du dich ja schlecht, weil du immer
denkst, durch den Augen der anderen bin ich halt total nichts wert und total scheiße, weil ich diesen Job mache. Und auch selber, wenn man mit sich vielleicht im Reinen ist und das einigermaßen gerne macht, dann ist es ja trotzdem irgendwie assi, das zu machen. Deswegen weiß ich nicht, ob es eine gute Idee war. Dankeschön für die Folge, derfo 35, Polis Prostitution, unsere Special-Folge. Wir hoffen, dieser kleine Themensprung hat euch ein bisschen gefallen. Und ihr bleibt uns treu. Spannende Diskussionen behalten wir euch vor für die nächsten Folgen. Und wir schreiben Text. Wir werden das machen, falls ihr wirklich Bock habt, uns zu unserem Traumhaus zu verhelfen. Och ne, machen wir das ja nicht, dann muss ich das Geld wieder zurückbeweisen, das war zau anstrengend. Wie sollst du das der Steuer erklären? Schreibt einfach mal bei Verwendungszweck für die Spende vielleicht rein, entweder das Haus oder Rocket Beans Tour, weil wie gesagt, wir sind bald bei Rocket Beans in Hamburg, moderieren, haben Spaß, haben eine coole Zeit, wollen mit ein paar Prostituierten sprechen, schlafen und sprechen. Wollen wir mal eine Prostituierte einladen? Also wirklich, jetzt mal ganz mehr ernst, falls ihr Prostituierte seid oder eine kennt und gerne in einen Podcast kommen würdet. Oder auch eine Pornodarstellerin, würde mich auch interessieren. Ja, das stimmt. Mit der kann man bestimmt total, also wenn die da irgendwie Bock drauf hat. Ja, man denkt immer mal mit denen super reden, aber man weiß, es ist einfach eine andere Welt, die wir leben. Ja, aber es ist ja interessant, mal in diese Welt einzusteigen so. Ja, wir haben sogar Schwierigkeiten, in Welten einzusteigen, die exakt unserer entsprechen, wie Maxi Stettenbauer. Wir sollten vielleicht erstmal eine Frau einladen und einfach mal generell gucken, ob wir es hinkriegen, mit einer Frau zu reden. Und dann vielleicht nachdenken, ob wir mit einer, der komplett außerhalb von unserem Kosmos lebt. Auf jeden Fall, schreibt uns auch, also falls ihr gute Ideen habt für einen Text, ihr könnt auch gerne einen eigenen Text schreiben, 200 Wörter und uns den schicken. Wir geben euch 200 Euro. Und wir geben euch 200 Euro und ihr dürft uns einmal besuchen.
Ihr kriegt dann ein Zimmer in unserer Villa.
Und ansonsten, was auf jeden Fall noch in den Text rein muss, schickt uns einfach Ideen und Sachen.
Schreibt uns nette Kommentare, nette Reply.
Wir freuen uns auf alles, was ihr so zu bieten habt in euren kleinen, dummen Gedächtnissen.
Das war's von uns. Wir sind raus.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.